[Music]
meat piece was Otto Frank's secretary
and she was a very close friend of the
Frank family they actually met in 1933.
she was the first person he asked when
he decided they needed to go and hide in
the annex and she immediately said yes
I knew the first thing I needed to do
was come to Amsterdam in order to step
into meat's shoes because it's such an
iconic City and I needed to be here to
really feel like her
[Music]
I made sure that I went to the Anne
Frank house I'd actually never been
before
I went there I took a private tour they
actually took me into some places they
don't allow everyone to go in
I got to go in Otto's office which was
heavy and has a very weighted feeling to
it but was really kind of important and
great for me to be able to feel that and
I could literally sit at meep's desk and
look out the window and she would have
looked out of our show Runners Tony and
Joan gave me a map of all of meeps
places that she lived and the roots that
she would cycle I went to her old
apartment
I cycled her route to work
I cycled the route that she took Margot
through the checkpoint and I just cycled
around this beautiful city and kind of
soaked in the feeling of being here it
just allowed me to create a really good
base for being this person just existing
in the place that she actually existed
in was really really useful to me
we're very lucky that we were able to
actually film here for a month which I
thought was incredibly important because
this is such an iconic City that
operates in a very certain way so it was
just really important to us to get into
the feeling of being here
when we shot some of the exteriors in
Amsterdam in the middle of the shoot we
actually shot outside of my way to plane
which is the Frank's last apartment
before they moved into the annex
we need to get that before they open the
checkpoint it was a very heavy and
intense day but it was also felt like a
great honor and we all had a very deep
respect for the weight of History we had
on our shoulders on that day and it was
pretty special to just feel that full
circle
of course she was an incredible person
she had a very strong sense of what's
right and what's wrong it's not going to
change anything it will change you it
she never wanted to be called a hero
which I think was important for me to
remember she wanted us all to see a bit
of ourselves in her it really has meant
a lot to me playing this role and I
really hope you watch and enjoy the
series if I don't try
[Music]
to live with myself